I just sneezed right before I sneezed
half a second it goes like hi all right
we have a new sonic trailer actually a
new sonic trailer we could call it the
first sonic trailer it's the first real
sonic trailer and the first real look at
Sonic the Hedgehog as Sonic the Hedgehog
I'm in my normal attire of [ __ ] given
because I gave a [ __ ] actually I do care
about this one I was one of the YouTube
[ __ ] that kind of piled on me hey he
kind of looks stupid and they were like
okay cool we'll fix him which I gotta
give him props for that so many people
just go like oh whatever fans what do
you know our executives we had a room
full of minds who do corporate marketing
behind this character design what do you
know that they don't know except the
entirety of the character they were like
cool alright we'll do that which is
great for fans I think great for them
it'll be great for them in the sense
that maybe people will like the movie
maybe they won't but I know most people
would hate the movie simply based on the
original character design if they had
just doubly kept it so props to them and
props to everyone who most likely worked
overtime to give Sonic the Hedgehog the
character design that actually looks
like Sonic the Hedgehog he does he does
look like Sonic the Hedgehog he no
longer looks like a kid who landed on
the wrong square of Jumanji and turned
into that blue abomination whoa what
does that mean what am I going to turn
into
Oh what am i he actually looks like
Sonic the Hedgehog and I'm not gonna lie
to you I didn't hate the trailer I had
fun with it maybe it's because the new
and improved character design we'll call
it the more accurate character design
just helped bring me into it and I feel
like this trailer had more fun I had
more personality
all right nothing's gonna change the
fact that it is Sonic the Hedgehog who
finds a portal to our worlds because
it's a video game adaptation so it feels
it has to do that the Sonic was cool he
was cocky he's playing games by himself
we've all done that who hasn't played
those tabletop games by themselves
because they got no one else to play
with none of you but the movie seems to
have that all brought to a world that's
completely foreign to me
fish-out-of-water feeling kind of like
you know Wonder Woman or Crocodile
Dundee they kind of have that flash spin
on it you know they're having fun with
the speedster powers either flash or
Quicksilver I don't know they have
references to both like et if et had the
powers of the flash who plot twist James
Marston in this movie he's actually
Elliot all grown up only in headcanon I
suppose Jim Carrey as dr. Robotnik even
in the first trailer with the speedy
monstrosity given in that first trailer
it was like yeah but Jim Carrey has
Robotnik might be cool yeah I had fun
with this movie it might be rule of
contrast working right here role of
contrast is like when you have such a
deep contrast between two examples the
second example we'll look more extreme
based on the initial example like hey
you just won 1 million dollars I did now
you actually won $100,000 I mean
$100,000 is no joke anyone can use that
but seist up against the million dollars
yes thought you just had that you just
found out you didn't have might be more
disappointing than if someone was just
like hey you won $10,000 I did now you
just want $100,000 now it seems just
insane rule of contrast so when you give
us an initial sonic trailer with the
blue douche face and a second trailer
that completely fixes it up and now he
looks like Sonic the Hedgehog that
second one's gonna see miles more
entertaining possibly more entertaining
now because we got the first trailer
with that first Sonic face the point is
I'm entertained by the trailer I had fun
with the trailer and I'm glad they fixed
the character design I don't be there to
watch this movie I kind of got to see
the saga through I said the new Sonic
the Hedgehog trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it what do you
think of the fixed character design
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]